[Music]
so for the drinkers in this room would
it be a dream come true if your faucet
all of a sudden had alcohol instead of
water Wow no that would be a problem I
think you like variety or just one kind
of alcohol I kind of I usually stick to
one kind for the most part but is it
this one it's one kind of one type
no he brought that one I brought this
one what Tim's a fan so he brought it
brought it for you guys
well a fan gave us one at the danger
boys meaning grief and I think we drank
it all I think we do oh yeah you're
drinking that I pretend that I didn't I
see when I'm like hanging out with
people and they all know who I am okay
well what if it was that alcohol coming
out of your faucet man I feel like I
don't know man I feel like that you know
too much when it's just there like that
I feel like I've died either get sick of
it or I would just just drink myself
into a good ditch you know me yeah I
need water what my neighbor like I went
to his check out his pool house and he
put in a kegerator so he has three of
his favorite beers on you it's literally
like out of a faucet he could drink that
much see I think beers not as bad
because
beer beer is filling like after like one
of these I'd be like I'm good yeah true
and I'm saying but this year right here
that's what I need water regulate
otherwise I can't I'll fall asleep with
beer ya know with like hard liquors come
on my faucet yeah I'm um dead asleep
do you have a drink of choice part vodka
sort of lime usually [ __ ] I sort of line
yeah but I like tequila the best I wish
I could drink yeah you're allergic
something happens to me makes me sad
makes me sick
oh it's not good for your good maybe
well gin and tonic is the only drink
that I've been surviving on so far
survived it's also depressant too so if
you're if you're not like emotionally
whatever it can [ __ ] with you yeah are
you guys how do you guys get when you're
drunk cuz you know there's like the sad
and there's the happy drunk I get
happiest I'm just relaxed super loving
okay I love everyone and everything
I get happier and [ __ ] sleepy yeah I
get I can I can for some reason hone in
even harder on something yeah oh well
maybe you think you're anyone's like God
it's true true pounding right now
usually I'm more talking about like what
I'm writing something it just helps me
just get sucked all the way into it oh
wow maybe it removes all the extra
[ __ ] extra thoughts yeah I'll get
these thoughts away me what you think
it's funny that you say that because um
when I used to do a lot of the like the
rap shows with all the Asian YouTube
right missed those those were so fun my
thing was that I would always forget at
least one or two like lyrics you know
always I love that I always [ __ ] up
but the one time I was hosting a show we
did in Toronto and I was also performing
I was I was drinking all night and then
I like I literally don't even remember
performing you know I'm saying I was so
drunk but the next day everyone's like
yo you didn't forget I've always been
drinking but those girls were the Hany
days and I just I was like oh [ __ ] well
I guess it just cleared all like like
just any self-consciousness I had I'll
just like I you know just oh I remember
I drank be Coronas and then I wanted to
be like a blues musician and play my
friends guitar and I was like why can't
I control my fingers and I just started
puking
you're drunk is your plastic about to
play guitar I bigger than everybody like
oh [ __ ] we didn't know what Joe could
take it's hard they're all gathered
became Cinelli guitar you know me so
cool alright well speaking of alcohol
and all this there were 18 families in
this town in southern India that found
alcohol not water coming out of their
their faucet kids yeah so this is an
apartment building and so that's why
there's 18 families and so about six
years ago what ended up happening was
that officials seized about 6,000 liters
or 1585 gallons of liquor from a bar
nearby that was stored illegally and so
after they discovered it they like the
officials ordered to destroy it and the
way they decided to destroy it was by
digging a hole in the property and
pouring the alcohol into amazing and so
they leap into the well water system
well of this apartment my god and this
is a six year process in being inside it
moving it's like Indian vodka god it was
probably just everything they had in
that store so it's like a [ __ ] jungle
juice what's that Indian beer oh man I
forgot the name of it this thing I don't
know no that's Thai no I always see it
at the Indian restaurants these families
ended up being like what the [ __ ] we
can't even shower like everything is
because they could smell the alcohol
coming out and then they would go the
next-door neighbor be like hey what's up
with you is your water good disinfect
your cut stop [ __ ] except for the drunk
uncle he's having a blast he doesn't
have to pay any money true so then they
ended up finding out the fact that it
was six years ago as when I started so
they've been drinking and swimming and
alcohol this whole time that whole
building's been all happy and [ __ ]
and that's like what happened to the
water
it's boring now I think my showers
aren't fun like that you mean well yeah
so they're just saying that they're now
gonna look into how to fix the situation
but by fixed they mean how to get the
alcohol back in the water I'm scared of
alcohol why because it makes me sick and
it's a roulette and usually I fail I
like that you keep playing them good for
you man I've been praying and it's been
working for gin is it like even a
specific brand of jam don't know I just
been ordering gin and tonic cuz it's
been safe do you say G T's do you say
can't get a G&T
no I tell my friends to go order it
they're like what do you want
gin and tonic okay and then they give it
to me I've known Joe for like 13 years
or maybe longer and I've only seen him
buzzed once one time when was that I
don't know what do you remember I think
we were in San Francisco and your
champagne
oh and you're having the time of your
life that's when our friend put on your
high heels and started dancing around he
was like that's how it feels like to be
tall I was he stunk old sober he was
drunk
I gave him my shoes no he put on your
shoes you didn't gave it to him he he
got on your back and he's like this hat
feels to be Tom is awesome this is crazy
no he put on he put on our high heels
and he started walking around he goes
this is how it feels like to be tall
this is how you like to have pretty lips
yeah I stopped them I mean I know I just
saying cuz I stopped like getting drunk
drunk like hardcore like that when I do
events and [ __ ] because um knowing you
and David still pound alcohol itself we
we okay yeah the last time I was
probably drunk like like blacked out
don't really remember [ __ ] was when we
did an episode of San foods and they
told me on one of them you broke his
back I heard you're drunk and then he
was kind of drunk and he just jumped on
him and he wasn't ready Neil's like oh
he [ __ ] his back crack like 20 times
he's gonna break I yeah I do well when I
get drunk enough I just i black out and
I don't remember things and that's why I
stopped getting drunk like that unless
you know like I'm shooting send food
because there's there's people around
yeah but I just man that day was that it
was like I was like sounds like spitting
oh I kept I can't
I was drinking gin this is that when you
kept spitting at your cat yeah yeah I'm
spitting at Davi and I was sitting at
the camera and like like this rate it's
not the [ __ ] that Lika
oh yeah I was doing like Triple H like
like all over you and I'm saying and
yeah I was I was a met but the next day
I remember it because I don't remember
being that drunk and then and then I was
looking at my shoes and like it was a
quiet all over them and then outside the
expensive shoes there were some really
nice air maxes and I'm taking a break
I'm like you know I think I was kind of
drunk yesterday he's like you were
[ __ ]
I was like yeah damn and and and here's
the thing you know when people remind
you that you're drunk you start
remembering more parts of your night and
and I remember cuz it was this was in
Huntington Beach ish and you know
sometimes you don't want to catch an
uber where everything's busy so you're
like I'm just gonna walk to the nearby
establishment and I think I'll walk for
like like three miles bro because I by
yourself
by myself just drunk and I just was like
I'm just gonna walk and then I remember
walking for a long-ass [ __ ] time
before I called my uber yeah do that
buzzed walked through Costa Rica like
without shoes and cuz I cuz the [ __ ]
place didn't take our card they didn't
take cards I mean now that when we
showed up so I had to go try to find an
ATM so we could pay and I had I walked
like three miles and didn't even really
and then in the dark with cars like
[ __ ] me on in Costa Rica Costa Rica
on the side of the road there monkeys
and stuff that was monkeys around but
not not exactly in my way monkeys there
I say I love your brain
one more drunk walking story the
drunkest event is that I didn't realize
that I am I pissed myself while walking
you know in in Orlando that's blackout
yeah that's what because I didn't even
remember I did it until the next day I
was so once I don't want on your shoes
no this is different this year cuz I put
on my vans the next day in the hotel I
woke up I put on my bands like wow my
shoes way
and I was like oh did I piss myself
that's three tomorrow then I remember I
cuz when I get really drunk I do the
Irish goodbye where I just leave I don't
tell anybody you bellicose school I was
good bye I learned that like a year ago
head north at along that yeah okay so I
was out I was hosting a club event and I
just left cuz I was so drunk and then
now after I smelled my shoes it all came
back to me right so I remember I was
walking home and I was like man I gotta
pee so bad and I was like I have black
jeans on I can just pee and no one would
know so just walking and teen and then
like running into fans drunk you is
you're like you're like hungover it's
like That's So Raven when you go comes
back did you wash I like that your
memory comes back from oh no it's
completely different than how I remember
it in school but his dick was out
anyways pee a little
oh my god I picture during the picture
you're like geez and it's like [ __ ]
exactly let's do it I'll do it
[Music]
[Music]